What are Co-linear and Co-planar points?
How many lines can we draw through one point?
We can draw one like this,
another one like this and many more!
Infinite lines can be drawn through one point.
What about two points?
How many lines can be drawn passing through both these points?
Just one!
One and only one line
can be drawn passing through two given points.
Now here's an interesting one.
How many lines can be drawn passing through three given points?
Okay, look at these three points.
We cannot draw a single line passing through all three of these points.
But, if we have three points placed like this,
were exactly one line passes through them,
then the points are called co-linear points.
Remember three points are co-linear,
if exactly one line passes through each of them.
Then what are these three points called?
Simple, they are called non co-linear points.
Co-linear if one line passes through them.
Non Co-linear if a line does not pass through them.
So wait, three collinear points are special. They form a line.
But what's special about three non co-linear points?
Three non co-linear points form exactly one plane.
If we have three non co-linear points like this,
exactly one plane will pass through them.
Will four or more non co-linear points always form a plane?
Not necessarily! But if they do, they are called Co-planar points.
Understand these concepts well.
Three points are co-linear
if exactly one line passes through them.
Exactly one plane passes through three non co-linear points.
And a four or more points form a plane
they are called co-planar.
Co-planar is basically one plane.
So when are two or more lines Co-planar?
Easy! If the lines lie on one plane, they are co-planar.
Two or more lines lying on the same plane
are called Co-planar lines.
When are two lines not co- planar?
If two lines do not lie on the same plane like this,
then they are non co-planar.
And we look at one last combination of a line and a point.
Will they lie on one plane?
Yes, a line and a point will always lie on a plane.
Exactly one plane.
It doesn't matter how you position the point or the line.
You can move them both as you wish.
You will always have one plane passing through them.